what kind of signal in our lifetime what
kind of thing you do you think might
happen
could possibly happen
where the scientific Community would be
convinced that
there's alien civilizations out there
like what uh she already said maybe a
strong infrared signature for something
like a Dyson Sphere yeah that's possibly
that that's always at some degree a
little bit ambiguous
um because that's a challenge sorry to
interrupt is where
your brain would be like you as a
scientist would be like I know it's
ambiguous but this is really weird yeah
I think
if you had some I can imagine something
like a prime number sequence
or a mathematical sequence like the
Fibonacci series something being
broadcastable that this is not a
physical phenomenon right I mean yeah
prime numbers is a pretty good case
because there's no natural phenomena
that produces prime number sequences it
seems to be a purely an abstract
mathematical concept as far as I'm aware
and so if we detected uh you know if she
was a radio blips that were following
that sequence it would be pretty clear
to me or it could even be uh in a car
Sagan suggested that Pi could be encoded
in that or you might use the hydrogen
line but multiply by pi like some very
specific uh frequency of the universe
like a hydrogen line but multiply it by
a abstract mathematical constant that
would imply strongly that there was
someone behind the scenes operating that
um apple as sorry stored in which
phenomena though there's a thing of a
radio wave but the information I mean we
kind of toyed with this um
uh idea in a video I did about
hypothetical civilization on my channel
but one kind of fun way I do want to
bring the this conversation towards time
a little bit and thinking about
um not just looking for life and
intelligence around us right now but
looking into the past and even into the
future to some degree or communicating
with the future and so we had this fun
experiment of imagining a civilization
that was born at the beginning of the
history of the Galaxy and being the
first and what it would be like for them
and they were desperately searching for
evidence of life but couldn't find it
and so they decided to try and leave
something behind for future
civilizations to discover to tell them
about themselves but of course a radio
thing just not going to work there
because it has have a power source and
that's a piece of Machinery it's going
to eventually break down it's gonna be
hard to maintain that for billions of
years time scale and so you wanted
something that was kind of passive that
doesn't require an energy source but can
somehow transmit information which is
hard to think about something that
satisfies those criteria but there was a
proposal by one of my colleagues Connor
which inspired a lot of us in tetna
signatures and he suggested that you
could build artificial transiters so you
could be build sheets of material that
transit in front of the star maybe one
thin sheet passes across first then two
then three then five and seven so you
could follow the prime number sequence
of these and so there'd be a clear
indication that someone had manufactured
those but they don't require any energy
source because they're just sheets of
material in orbit of the star they would
eventually degrade from micrometeorite
so maybe that orbits would become
destabilized but they should have
lifetimes far exceeding the lifetime of
any uh battery or mechanical electronic
system that we could at least without
technology conceive of building and so
you can imagine in extending that and
how could you encode not just a prime
number sequence but maybe in the spatial
pattern of this very complex light curve
we see you could encode more and more
information through 2D shapes and the
way those occupations happen and maybe
uh you could even encode messages and
and in-depth information from you know
you could even imagine it being like a a
lower layer of information which is just
the prime number sequence but then you
look closely and you see the smaller
divots embedded within those that have a
deeper layer of information to extract
um and so to me something like that
would be pretty compelling that there
was somebody who would mind if unless
it's just a a very impressive hoax that
would be a pretty compelling evidence in
this civilization and actually the
methods of
um astronomy right now are kind of
marching towards
being able to better and better detect a
signal like that yeah I mean to some
degree it's just building bigger
aperture in Space the bigger the
telescope the the finer ability to
detach those minute signals do you think
the current sort of the scientific
Community another weird question but
just the observations that are happening
now do you think they're ready for a
prime number sequence in in the um so if
if we're using the current method the
transit timing variation method like do
you think
you're ready do you have the tools to
detect the prime number sequence
yeah for sure I mean there's
200 000 stars that Kepler monitored and
it monitored them all the time it took a
photo of each one of them every 30
minutes measured their brightness and it
did that for four and a half years and
so you have already and Tess is doing it
right now another mission and so you
have already an existing catalog and
people are uh genuinely scouring through
each of those light curves with
Automated machine learning techniques or
even developed some on our own team that
can look for weird Behavior we wrote a
code called the weird detector for
instance that of course you know it was
just the most generic thing possible let
don't assume anything about the signal
shape just look for anything that
repeats the distinguish rate can be
anything can we kind of learn the
template of the signal from the data
itself and then we it's like a template
matching filter to see if that repeats
many many times in the data and so we
actually applied that and found a bunch
of interesting stuff but we didn't see
anything that was the prime number
sequence at least on the Kepler data
that's 200 000 Stars which sounds like a
lot but compared to you 200 billion
stars in the Milky Way it's really just
scratching the surface so one because
there could be something much more
generalizable than the prime number
sequence it's ultimately the question of
a signal that's very difficult to
compress
in the general
sensible compressed means so maybe as we
get better and better machine learning
methods that automatically figure out
analyze the data to to understand how to
compress it just you'll be able to
discover data that's for some reason
it's not compressible
but then you know compression really is
a bottomless pit because like that's
really what intelligence is is being
able to compress information yeah and to
some degree the more you I would imagine
I don't work in compression algorithms
but I would imagine the more you
compress your signal
um the the more assumptions that kind of
go on behalf of the decoder the more
skilled they really have to be you know
some of the a prime number sequence is
completely unencoded information
essentially but um if you look at the
Arecibo message
they were fairly careful with their
pixelation of this simple uh image they
sent to try and
make it as interpretable as possible to
be that even a Dom alien would be able
to figure out what we're trying to show
them here because there's all sorts of
conventions and rules that are built in
that we we tend to presume when we
design our messages and so if your
message is assuming they know how to do
an MP3 decoder particular compression
algorithm I'm sure they could eventually
reverse engineer it and figure it out
but you're you're making it harder for
them to get to that point so maybe I
always think you probably would have a
two-tier system right you'd probably
have some lower tier key system and then
maybe beneath that you'd have a deeper
compressed layer of more in-depth
information